femme engagée notamment pour la cause
palestinienne
christiane hessel est venu appeler les
nouvelles générations résisté face à
toute forme de xénophobie
les signes sont toujours les mêmes et
sont reconnaissables doit être
immédiatement combattu c'est le message
que nous laisse qui nous ont pas aidés
dont la lutte pour la liberté pour la
dignité à plus de 90 ans elle a tenu à
assister à l'inauguration de ce nouveau
centre de la résistance de la
déportation a de la mémoire
car elle est très attachée à blois ça
remonte à pierre ce drone qui était un
ami de bruneval de mon mari qui nous a
amenés ici
à l'époque il était même beaucoup de de
lui rendre marge aujourd'hui parce que
c'était une grande personnalité et un
homme de vraie éthique est de bras
fidélité
le nouveau lieu de mémoire de blois
remplace le musée de la résistance plus
excentrés en bord de loire
un peu moins d'objets et de photos plus
d'animation numérique et de pédagogie
ce centre a pour objectif d'attirer plus
de scolaires et de touristes c'est
important surtout de poursuivre notre
idée de défendre notre liberté
et puis
c'était normal qu'on ait connu quand
même parce que qu'on se trouver bientôt
un peu trop éloignée et là ça va
favoriser le tourisme en deux et puis
surtout poursuivre notre notre désir de
ne pas oublier seul bémol ce qu'ils ont
connu l'ancien musée n'ont pas retrouvé
toutes les photos et tous les objets qui
pouvaient transmettre plus d'émotions
aux visiteurs c'est une muséographie
nouvelle génération qui peut
déstabiliser les derniers résistants et
leurs familles